my king we have her corner
hey guys bliss con 2017 is in full swing
I'm Justin hey well joined by Eric Tay
we got to play around a little bit with
the next World of Warcraft expansion
battle for Azeroth now there are a lot
of announcements here around what's
gonna be coming next for World of
Warcraft but I think the most exciting
the most interesting thing is that
there's gonna be a classic server
there's gonna be legacy World of
Warcraft like vanilla World of Warcraft
is coming back that's that's insane I'm
actually more excited for that honestly
than I am for the newest expansion only
because it's nostalgia for me I spent so
many hours so many days so many months
playing World of Warcraft vanilla this
has been something the communities
wanted for a long time to the point
where people were making their own kind
of like modded servers that Blizzard had
to ultimately take down and then
Blizzard basically realized okay this is
a thing that people really want to do
and I think you got more insight in
terms of like what the devs are doing at
Blizzard with this classic mode yeah so
this is obviously a a still very new
thing so all that we saw at Blizzcon was
basically a cinematic introducing this
thing but but talking with the
developers it's something that they're
working on from the ground up on the
development side they're not outsourcing
this to the teams that have done some of
the legacy servers in the past like this
is something that the guys who
originally worked on the game are
working on and trying to get right for
them and there are a lot of questions
they they have to answer which is why I
think this is taking a long time now
they said they've been working on it for
about a year now and I don't know how
soon this is gonna come out we didn't
get a date but you know there is a lot
to think about and the thing that they
brought up is there's been so many
changes to World of Warcraft and vanilla
wow isn't necessarily a fun experience
in a lot of ways so what things do you
bring back over what things do you keep
what things are great about the current
world of warcraft that you want to bring
over to vanilla that are just gonna make
that a better experience versus what
kinds of things are gonna embody that
classic vanilla experience so like
that's the kind of stuff that they're
balancing now like what parts do we keep
what parts do we get rid of yeah I think
that's gonna be a tough balance and it's
like funny because like how much does
the community want that like real true
vanilla Wow versus do they want
just like that experience but kind of
retexture right like a remaster of
vanilla Wow like what what is where they
gonna head it's gonna be hard to say
obviously I think just having vanilla
Wow
might be on its own like I don't know
touch touchy a little bit do you really
want to go back to those original
graphics do you want to go back to all
of the old systems that were in place
that are or in a lot of ways better now
it's more streamlined but at the same
time like that and body is that original
experience and those are the things
their way the other thing that they I
didn't get a clear answer on is how this
is going to be integrated into the game
is this gonna be a completely separate
thing is this gonna be something that's
part of your main World of Warcraft
subscription is this something you have
to pay for separately those are the
other kinds of things that they're
deciding like maybe this will be
something that you could go to a
character and he'll put warp you over to
this this other instance of the realm
maybe it'll be a completely standalone
separate thing and those are the things
that they're talking about that they
just don't have answers for right at the
moment I think the other cool thing that
we didn't expect to see obviously was
the interest cinematic for the battle
for Azeroth which was amazing I feel
like I say this every Blizzcon but like
Blizzard and their partners always find
a way to just really deliver on
cinematics like I'd rather have a
cinematic like Wow movie then you know
the real-life one we got but yeah what
are your thoughts on that it was kind of
surprising because Legion is still
wrapping up so you wouldn't expect to
see battle for Azeroth cinematic quite
yet but you know it's that it brings us
back to that classic World of Warcraft
works versus humans and that's kind of
been missing for a long time like in a
lot of ways it's felt like we're we're
getting closer to just being one
singular army and this puts a clear
divide between what faction are you
choosing are you for the Horde are you
for the Alliance and it feels like it's
going to really focus on that aspect of
the gameplay which was it's so central
both to the original RTS and kind of to
the original Warcraft experience yeah so
battle for Azeroth is just announced now
it'll be coming out sometime next year
we have no idea when those classic
servers are coming but just the fact
that they announced them now means it
can't be too much longer before and you
get to try it out in some way maybe on
PTR but for even more World of Warcraft
news for some hearthstone maybe a little
bit
over watch stay tuned to gain spot calm